[Music]
so at the very start of trump's
presidency
one of the promises that he made was
that he was going to take
his salary and donate it to various
government agencies throughout
the time that he was in office and they
made a big show of this they would come
out
in the white house press briefing room
with these huge
checks and they would transfer with this
oversized check a 78 000 or a 100
000 amount of money from trump's bank
account
into whichever government agency he was
supporting
[Music]
but what they weren't showing was all of
the enormous amount of money that trump
was continuing to collect
of course his government salary for him
was pocket change
where he was really making his money was
through the business that he had decided
to hang on to
when he took office and if you add up
all of that revenue coming in
through the four years that he's in
office that comes to about 2.4 billion
dollars
the biggest chunk of money is through
sort of his golf clubs and golf resorts
[Music]
so this is doral down in miami he owns
three resorts
in europe and he owns about a dozen golf
clubs here in the united states
if you look at the next biggest revenue
generator that's sort of his
commercial real estate so think big
broad shoulder buildings in new york
things on fifth avenue on 61st
street sort of right in the center of
manhattan he has really the core of his
empire
and that all that brought in about 780
million dollars
then the next biggest chunk is this
hotel
licensing management empire this is
probably trump's most famous part of his
business so people love for example
to talk about the dc hotel that's right
down the street from
the white house and he's got a big hotel
in las vegas another one in chicago
but these are also really tricky
businesses and they're not the most
profitable businesses
they're not even huge revenue generators
when you compare them to
the golf business and the commercial
real estate business
[Music]
trump when he took office he didn't stop
selling things
and included in the things that he was
selling were a lot of plots of land and
condos
and these were in many cases
multi-million dollar sales
he sold a penthouse in new york for
about 16 million dollars so
land down in the dominican republic for
about 3 million
it seemed like every other week he was
selling condos in las vegas
all of this stuff was coming into his
pockets while he's serving from various
sources many of which frankly
we don't know who they are because they
were shielding their identities when
they were making those purchases
if you add up all of that stuff it adds
up to about 118 million dollars
one of the interesting things there is
that almost all of that 118 million
dollars
came in the first three years of trump's
presidency
during covid although he was trying to
sell things for example like his
hotel in washington dc he didn't have
much luck nobody was willing to pay him
the prices that he wanted
and so suddenly a big cash stream for
him
just went totally dry beyond there
there's just sort of a
big mix of things so trump is still
collecting money from the art of the
deal
from the time that he appeared in home
alone 2 he had a skating rink
in central park he has restaurants in
the basement of trump tower he's got all
of these different things
that combine bring in money and if you
add all those up
that helps create the balance of that
2.4 billion dollars
that he generated during his time in the
white house